let's go on to the next question from
Emmy Emmy said how willing are you to
actually cancel your cable and internet
service how willing are you to cancel
the yes well okay I think that it's
written in a way that I may have read it
wrong but the question is am I willing
to cancel cable internet if net
neutrality is repealed because what Emmy
says is that if everybody isn't willing
to do this
why would Internet service providers pay
attention to our protests if people are
just going to keep subscribing to their
Comcast or their AT&T whatever it is
that they have who cares if you don't
want a net neutrality repealed you're
still going to be a customer and the
answer is I am not really willing to
cancel because we need the internet for
our work there we the only thing we have
available here at the studio other than
getting some outrageously expensive
fiber or satellite installation for
Internet is Comcast so what can we
really do I can cancel Comcast and we'll
save a hundred and sixty bucks a month
we'll take away a hundred and sixty
bucks a month from them but then we
can't distribute the show which seems to
me like a net loss yeah I mean maybe
cable alone you able to neither you're
canceling cable TV but they screw you
when you do that too because then they
say oh sure you can cancel the TV part
it'll just double the price of the
internet that you want to keep yeah I
feel like people who are already
considering canceling their cable
subscription because maybe they're now
looking at Netflix and Hulu and yeah
YouTube right I mean you've already left
know if they're what they've already but
they still need the internet part yes in
order to access those those services so
this is a problem it's a problem and you
know what the fact that it's so hard to
cut the cord with these companies is
proof that we should be labeling and
regulating those companies as common
carriers because so many businesses
depend on having an internet connection
through these companies and that itself
should tell us it's not about will you
cancel if net neutrality is repealed
it's about oh it's so abundantly clear
that this is a utility at this point it
is not a luxury it is a utility that it
should be regulated as a common carrier
like the phone for example yeah and I
mean in so many different parts of
country you don't have this wide variety
of choices when it comes to what
Internet service provider you want to
use most of the mobile carrier what you
want to use do you have a little more
say with mobile right right you've got
like there's all more options or
something you've got four options and
then there are like some prepaid ones
that you can do which are often just
subsidiaries of the big four the big
four are what Verizon Sprint t-mobile
and AT&T yeah and then you've got like
boot is Boost Mobile part of one of them
I think it is looking it's like Google
thigh which I guess uses like t-mobile
and Sprint and US Cellular I think it's
its own thing yeah that's that's coming
of age I guess we should check Pat's
internet history that's probably a
treasure trove of interesting stuff I've
cleared it oh you have cleared okay good